bonjour à tous Nous sommes à la ferme de
bbas théâtre de guillancour nous allons
rcontrer Laurent maless le metteur en
scène des 7 jours de Simon Labrosse une
pièce comique oscilant entre espoir et
désespoir mais tout ça dans la bonne
humeur c'est
parti bonjour Laurent macls bonjour vous
êtes donc ici à la ferme de bb en
résidence de création pour la pièce les
7 jours de Simon la brosse est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire déjà qu'est-ce qui
qu'est-ce qui vous a donné envie de
mettre en scène cette pièce alors il y a
plusieurs choses qui m'ont donné envie
de monter la
pièce d' d'abord ben d'abord il faut
faut un coup de cœur pour monter une
pièce donc il y a un coup de cœur sur un
texte sur un texte qui est très très
actuel euh tant tant dans sa forme que
que sur le fond c'est que l'écriture est
très directe très presque j'aime pas le
terme de quotidien par c'est presque un
espèce de nivellement mais c'est c'est
du langage très
simple voilà contemporain et
et donc ça ça c'est c'est cette form là
qui m'a qui m'a plu il y a aussi
la poésie que les personnages
développent dans dans ce dans ce cette
pièce c'est qui une poésie qui n'est pas
sous la forme Alexandrine et cetera mais
c'est une espèce de c'est plutôt de
posite de leur de leur caractère et leur
personnalité qui me qui me qui m'ont
beaucoup touché et ce qui m'a aussi
beaucoup motivé c'est que c'est une
pièce qui parle d'un problème enfin d'un
problème d'une situation qui est très
très actuelle pour beaucoup beaucoup de
gens c'està dire c'est quelqu'un qui est
en dehors
un petit peu en dehors de de de la
société et qui essaie de rentrer dedans
quelqu'un en fait on sait pas quel âge
il là il pourrait avoir je pense 40
presque même jusqu'à 50 ans pouvez nous
rappeler un petit peu justement le
contexte le contexte de la pièce c'est
très très simple
c'est un jeune homme moi j'ai pris je
l'ai pris jeune relativement jeune un
jeune homme qui est donc au chômage et
qui
organise une représentation de 7 jours
de sa vie pour recueillir de l'argent
qui va lui permettre de payer son loyer
de payer un getto blaster qui est un
appareil pour écouter de la musique et
et enregistrer des messages et et
surtout de payer l'opération de son ami
d'enfance Léo qui a reçu une brique sur
la tête quand il était tout petit et qui
ça a été touché été touché au niveau du
cortex et qui ne peut plus avoir dire un
mot positif voilà moi j'arrive encore à
le dire mais lui il n arrive plus et
même chose il peut plus avoir une pensée
positive et néo donc une espèce de de
poète fou qui vit qui écrit ses poèmes
dans la cave euh des poème que lui-même
traite d'infecte et dégueulasse et euh
et et donc Simon qui est toujours
évidemment touché par le truc de son ami
voudrait aller le faire opérer euh à
Houston au Texas dans une clinique
spécialisée donc en fait c'est on suit
le personnage Simon voilà et ses deux
amis voilà et ces deux amis qui donc
Simon nous donne passion 7 jours de sa
vie Simon pour trouver du travail euh il
va pas se placer sur les créneaux où il
y a tout plein de monde il invente des
métiers qui vont qui dans dans son
esprit vont lui permettre justement
d'aller occuper des crréaux qui
n'existent pas donc eu alors des métiers
pas commun est d'accord parce que il est
à tour de rôle finisseur de phrases euh
remplisseur de de vide alors et c'est
très poétique c'est très altruiste enfin
donc qu'est-ce qui vous a plu là
justement dans dans l'écriture de de
Carole Fréchette alors on on rappelle
Carole frchette donc c'est une a auteur
québécoise qui a écrit cette pièce en 95
donc ça a presque 20 ans et c'est encore
complètement malheureusement d'actualité
un portrait un peu du du désarrois mais
dans la bonne humeur voilà voilà alors
moi c'est ça qui mea beaucoup PL c'est
c'est que justement c'est c'est que ça
se passe dans la bonne humeur c'est pas
l'ARM moyant ça ne prêche rien il y a
pas de il y a pas de message autre qu'un
espèce de miroir qui est tendu au aux
spectateurs sur sur son époque et et sur
ce sur quand même sur ce qu'il vit parce
que tous les métiers qu'il invente que
ce soit le spectateur personnel
spectateur personnel il a une fille qui
croise ce qui vous manque pour vous
sentir exister c'est quelqu'un qui vous
regarde et là on est complètement dans
le domaine du du du reality show show
des des de ces gens que ordinaires qu'on
filme et dont on fait des stars parce
qu'elles disent une
formule qu'elles ont travaillé avec un
un charger de com et cetera voilà et et
d'autres métiers comme finisseurs de
phrases qui posent des des des questions
qui sont très profondes parce que
finisseurs de phrases il finit les
phrases de gens qui ne son sont pas
capables de finir les leurs c'est-à-dire
en gros il dit moi j'ai la culture vous
ne l'avez pas et je vous la mets à vos
disposition moyennant la somme de ça
raisonne quand même désagréablement et
c'est vrai que c'est un petit peu quels
que soi les efforts qu'on fait c'est en
tout cas pour les gens qui n'ont pas la
culture et le reçoivent souvent comme ça
h je me
présente Simon Labrosse finisseur Simon
qui labros finisseur et comment ça
finisseur finisseur de phrase c'est ma
profession
vous voulez dire que vous les phrases
les en suspend ouais c'est ça que je
voulais dire mais vous voyez ça marche
parfaitement non mais là je comprends
pas je veux dire c'est quoi la c'est
quoi l'idée au juste ouais c'est quoi
l'idée c'est d'aller au
bout je dire aller au bout de de votre
idée je vous écoute depuis tout à
l'heure j' avis des choses à dire des
choses très importantes ouais c'est vrai
ça mais malheure ement c'est pas de
votre faute mais vous êtes incapable
d'aller au bout de votre pensée si vous
voulez moi je peux y aller pour vous
allez au bout c'est ma spécialité
comprenez-vous bah je je suis pas sûre
là toi évidemment la pensée ça dit rien
c'est trop fort pour toi e j'ai une
pensée de très développé tu sauras si je
l'exprime pas c'est juste parce que j'ai
pas assez de mot pour l'expliquer ouais
donc tous ces métiers touche à chaque
fois quelque chose phénomène de le
charity business
les cascadeur émotif c'est il prend il
prend la place des gens pour vivre les
situations désagréables enfin il y a des
tas de choses qui qui qui font que que
que tous ces métiers là en fait ils ont
l'air d'être complètement fantaisistes
et à chaque fois il nous renvoie un
phénomène de la société qui qui est qui
est très aigu voilà alors en ce qui
concerne la mise en scène les décors je
vous propose peut-être qu'on se retrouve
sur scène nous en parler ok on y
va
Laurent macls parlez-nous des décors
comment vous les avez pensé alors je les
ai d'abord pensé comme pas cher
h parce que c'est la réalité de Simon
c'estàd que c'est sont pas des gens qui
ont qui ont de l'argent donc il a dû se
débrouiller avec les moyens du bord
parce que on rappelle en fait Simon a
une idée original c'est de faire de sa
vie une représentation ouais en 7 jours
voilà va présenter 7 jours de sa vie à
un public pour tout ça pour gagner de
l'argent et pour résoudre ses problèmes
donc financiers je rassure les
spectateurs c'est pas une représentation
en 7 jours c'est une représentation en 1
heure et demi de 7 jours de sa vie voilà
donc donc CC je les ai voulu donc léger
et et ce qui m'intéressait c'est aussi
qu'on voit la qu'on voit le théâtre dire
queon le principe de de de la
scénographie c'est que Simon investit le
temps d'un soir ou de deux soirs un
plateau de théâtre euh
donc il a pas il a pas des gros moyens
donc j'ai pris j'ai pris des carcasses
d'uparavant parce que il y a dans dans
les carcasses d'uparavant il y a quelque
chose qui est qui qui est abstrait on
peut mettre ce qu'on veut euh dans dans
les dans les dans les espaces vides on
met ce qu'on veut et c'était ce qui
m'intéressé c'était que le spectateur
fasse de lui-même le travail imaginatif
alors on l'aide puisqueil y a surtout la
scénographie c'est elle est surtout
travaillé en relation avec la lumière de
Patrick Flores h HM et c'est c'est
surtout la lumière qui nous donne les
espaces donc le jeu de lumière est
vraiment important hein ah il est il est
il est essentiel mais de toute façon bon
dans le travail que je fais ça a
toujours été comme ça j'ai jamais voulu
des des du du décor lourd j'ai toujours
voulu du travail avec la lumière et et
donc avec en associant
le Patrick au niveau des de la création
au moment de des conceptions même des
choses donc euh pour moi c'était
essentiel donc donc décor très léger
carcasse d'uparavant de Ban une table je
crois que c'est jouv qui disait meilleur
décor pour jouer pour jouer du théâtre
c'est donnez-moi une table et de chaises
et avec ça je tout vous faire et moi je
j'adhère assez au principe attendez
l'argent je l'ai pas c'est vrai mais je
pourrais vous payer
autrement comment ça autrement en
service par
exemple quel genre de service j'en ai
tout un assortiment
ça dépend de vos besoins vous par
exemple
ouis je pourrais vous flatter me flatter
oui je suis flatteur d'ego c'est ma
profession je peux pas accepter c'est
l'argent ou la saisie c'est écrit mais
j'offre pas service là à n'importe qui
si je vous l'offre à vous c'est parce
que parce que vous êtes vraiment
quelqu'un d'exceptionnel vous
trouvez
absolument je l'ai compris tout de suite
quand vous êtes entré comment ça la
façon vous avez d'entrer chez les gens
avec un mélange de politesse et de
fermeté c'est très très
rare c'est vrai que à ce niveaau je suis
assez spéciale mais c'est pas tout votre
façon de
saisir vous emparer des bien d'autrui
comme ça avec une assurance une justesse
de
ton je vous le dis franchement j'ai
jamais vu ça vraiment alors aussi il y a
une difficulté contre les comédiens
parce qu'ils vont jouer des comédiens
amateurs comment vous les avez dirigé
là-dessus alors c'est c'était un souci
permanent pendant toutes les répétitions
et ça l'IT toujours hein c'est
qu'effectivement la difficulté de jouer
quand on est professionnel des amateurs
c'est qu'il faut souvenir du temps où on
était amateur en même temps on peut pas
offrir au public une représentation
d'amateur c'estit des professionnel qui
jou donc tout ce qui se dit ce se fait
dans la pièce et on est t toujours sur
ce questionnement qui parle est-ce que
c'est euh bon Simon lui c'est tout le
temps lui mais est-ce que c'est Léo
quand il est en postier ou est-ce qu'il
est un homme désagréable est-ce que
c'est Nathalie quand elle est en
hissière ou ou quand elle joue une une
jeune femme dans un café quelle est la
part de Natalie qui joue quelle est la
part du personnage voilà parce que les
amis ont en fait interprété toutes les
personnes qu' qui ont croisé à un moment
donné la vie de de Simon donc c'est vrai
que c'est c'est compliqué en terme de
jeu évidemment est-ce que quelle émotion
vous avez voulu aussi créer peut-être
avec les spectateurs parce que est-ce
que les spectateurs ont aussi un rôle
finalement les SPECT une interaction oui
il y a une interaction parce que des
fois carrément Simon arrête la
représentation en parlant au spectateur
des moments où où il y a des problèmes
sur le plateau il
demande au spectateur de l'excuser des
des agréments et cetera enfin et et tout
est fait c'est tout est fait un peu sur
ce principe là c'est qu'il y a 3 degrés
il y a euh il y a il y a le plateau de
théâtre il y a il y a donc le plateau
dans le plateau
c'estàd et puis l'espace spectateur qui
est aussi un espace de de de va et vien
de communication entre entre Simon
ou Nathalie ou Léo avec les spectateur
directement ça crée trois espaces de jeu
en fait bon écoutez merci beaucoup
Laurent malesès pour toutes ces
explications merci je suis très
intéressant
jeis me dire on a déjà la télé pour ça
mais moi je suis
live je veux
dire je suis vivant et je compte presque
rien
pensez-y j'ai laissé ma carte à la
sortie Simon la brosse remplisseur de
vide